when you go to vote at the local
elections in May it won't just be
posting a picture of your dog outside
the polling station you'll have to think
about this time you'll also have to
remember your own photo ID that's
because For the First Time an England
people will need to show that ID to cost
their vote at The Ballot Box problem is
there are potentially millions of people
without a valid form of ID who could be
turned away on voting day
and there's not only concern that this
could swing some of the results some
calling it voter suppression there's
also criticism that this is a move
towards national identity cards by the
back door
what's more a lot of people aren't even
aware these new rules are coming into
Force some councils like one in South
Norfolk are using well let's say
interesting ways to try and make
communities aware I've got something to
say about my local elections tdoc's been
in bars about build ID selection so make
sure you bring it or you'll receive
rejection the government though insists
they're needed this change is important
to protect the Integrity of your Ballot
Box and we should all get ready for it
in May but does it risk excluding some
in society just another obstacles people
from underprivileged backgrounds
so why the changes and what might it
mean for democracy
I'm Sally Lockwood and this is the Sky
News Daily
there's been a couple of Pilots but this
will be the first time for this podcast
I'm joined by our political
correspondent Liz Bates who's been
finding out about the nuts and bolts of
all this engaging opinion before that
you had to be registered but when you
turned up at a polling station you just
had to say your name and then you're
able to vote so this is a big change it
does happen already in other countries
in Europe across Northern Ireland but
for the UK this is the first time that
it will happen and it will kick in at
May's local elections when do people
need to get their free ID online by
because there is a deadline for that
isn't there yes the deadline is Tuesday
the 25th of April at 5 pm and what is
accepted as a valid form of Ideal is is
it just passports and driving licenses
or all the other things that other
people could use it's not there are
there are different forms of ID that are
accepted it's a rather arbitrary list
this is one of the problems actually
with the policy that um the government
have released a list of IDs many of them
are for older people things like travel
cards can be used you can find that list
online you can also apply for a free ID
if you want to most people will use a
passport or driver's license I imagine
how many people are there that don't
have one of these valid forms of ID it's
quite a wide-ranging uh estimate but
it's from around 900 000 to up to 3.5
million people and could be without a
valid ID so potentially huge numbers and
I think that's really what we're going
to be looking at at May's local
elections what is the impact of this
going to be on those elections the
government will be hoping that it's
minimal we won't know until the day
after May's local elections what the
impact of this is so Liz you say we
won't know whether this has impacted the
local election results until until
afterwards why is that the number of
people that actually physically turned
away from a police station that turned
up to vote that don't have their ID that
will be counted so we'll have a good uh
understanding of that there is a slight
problem with that though because there's
also an issue of turnout because they've
heard about voter ID and that it could
be a problem how many people will just
decide not to turn up and will be able
to tell from the turnout because
turnouts fluctuate across every election
sometimes the weather affects it people
um just feeling slightly disillusioned
with the political system generally so
we will know how many people get turned
away we won't know how many people just
decide not to turn up the suggestion is
that it's more likely to impact people
from a deprived background or the
elderly people who don't travel and
don't have a passport or don't drive a
car if you think about it intuitively
you can bring into your mind the type of
people that don't have a valid ID most
people drive a lot of people have
passports and travel abroad it tends to
be people from deprived backgrounds
vulnerable backgrounds very elderly
people I asked David Davis who's a
conservative MP about this issue he's
very much against it and the way he
breaks it down is he basically says this
is punishing uh poor and old people a
lot of elderly people who are no longer
go abroad on holidays they don't need a
passport no longer drives they don't
need a driving license and wonder why
the devil they're going to have these
things so you've got that and also of
course you've got poorer people you know
who can't afford those things either so
you know are we going to actually
discriminate against the old and the
poor in our election system basically if
you look at the groups of people that
may not have ID may not know the ID is
going to be necessary or be able to
access the free ID those are the types
of people that we're looking at and if
you dig into that people from black and
ethnic minority backgrounds will be
adversely effective people on disability
benefits and you know people who are
unable to access the internet unable to
fill in the forms things like that
there's a suggestion Liz that if these
people aren't eligible to vote because
they don't have one of these valid forms
of ID then it could even flip councils
in the local elections the analysis on
this is not particularly detailed there
have been accusations of voter
suppression and I have spoken to
conservative MPS who believe that part
of the government pushing forward this
policy is because they believe that the
people that don't have valid ID we are
mostly labor voters which is a very
serious accusation level that the
government if they think that this is
going to keep their vote basically at
the same level but suppress the
opposition vote to say that it might
flip councils it would have to really
have a bigger impact than the government
is expecting
um but we'll have to wait and see it is
possible let's turn our Focus now Liz
onto why these new rules for voter ID
are even being brought in and the debate
around them they say it's to prevent
voter fraud but how much is voter fraud
actually an issue this only addresses in
person voter fraud so people turning up
at a polling station and saying I'm Joe
blogs and they're actually not Joe blogs
they're somebody else
um and the incidence of that happening
in the UK is extremely low I think last
year it was one person was eventually
found to have done that there is a voter
fraud in the UK it's more subtle it's
about pressures from leaders within
certain communities it's often done via
postal votes and other means so the idea
that we are addressing an actual problem
of voter fraud in the UK
um I don't think even the government is
arguing that I think their argument is
it reduces the risk of voter fraud going
forward but as many people have said on
both sides of the house conservative and
labor MPS this is fixing a problem that
isn't there and I think one of the
questions that hasn't really been
answered by the government is when there
are so many other problems that need
fixing the country urgently why are you
pushing forward a policy that is fixing
a problem that doesn't exist
[Music]
um
now Liz you travel to Hull to speak to
young people there about this issue why
did you choose Hull and what did they
say to you about it Paul is lovely but
that's what that's not why we choose to
go to these places it was city of
culture wasn't it it was city of culture
and this is a lovely lovely place to
visit and I enjoyed myself very much but
yes so the reason that we chose Hull is
because of the demographics of the
people that will be affected by this
there are certain parts of the country
that will be more affected by it because
they have more of those kind of
vulnerable voters in those groups that
may not have voter ID and Hull is one of
those places we spoke to a group of
people that really are vulnerable to not
having a proper voter ID these were
young people in a community center in
Hull and they spoke to us about the
policy many of them had never heard of
it they raised a lot of concerns with us
based on what they know
um about their Community honestly it
just seems kind of pointless it's just
another obstacles people from
underprivileged backgrounds of modulus
so in terms of actual ID
passports and driving license is the
main form of ID do you know young people
in the area that wouldn't have that I
know some people that don't have either
of those and there's been a list of
other options published but a lot of
those for the over 60s
I think it's going to disproportionately
affect disabled and trans people more
than anyone else trans people especially
if you can't afford to renew your
license or your passport after
transitioning on during transition don't
look the same as your photo or more
likely to be challenged on our ID than
anyone else young people themselves are
struggling with job applications and
everything at the moment so voting and
trying to get free ID is our last
priority I didn't even know about the
free ID until this morning and I'm quite
lucky to have a provisional license and
I only got that because I it was bought
as a birthday present when I was 18. why
do you think the government is doing
this they say it's to
make sure there's no voting fraud
why do you think if they really cared
about voting as much as as they say they
would listen to us when we say to them
this is not what we need what we need is
somebody who will speak for us we need
more disabled people more trans people
more people running who were not born in
this country you know the whole voting
system is complicated within itself
never mind throwing an ID we have a big
issue with people of our age not voting
in this country because it's either
inaccessible they're not taught how or
they don't have a political system that
actually represents them do you think
this is high up on the list of things
that they that they should be doing
why are we spending money on something
that feels so pointless and exclusionary
some people might have disabilities that
they can't read or write and they need
help with it like I did once I had to
ask my number to help me do a voting
paperwork and it's like because I didn't
know like big words or how to like fill
one in so it was like that was my first
time doing one and ever since that I've
not voted there's also issues with
document access internet access uh
secure stable address to send that
document to and instead of spending this
money on swiping a sticker on the voting
system they could have put that same
money into education to run political
skills courses as a core part of
secondary education
one of the most interesting things they
said to us was they were very surprised
this was a government priority given the
problems that they saw around them in
Hull and it made them feel like the
government doesn't care about them and
that they're incredibly out of touch
with what people actually need and what
they care about how much effort has the
government gone to to actually publicize
this change to make sure that people are
informed prior to the local elections
well not much
um there has been I think a campaign by
the Electoral commission there's really
three problems with this and one of them
is implementation and awareness so the
government I think you could argue that
they haven't done enough to make sure
that people are aware of the changes and
the free ID that's available the other
thing that we hear is from councils who
say they haven't been given enough time
and resources and guidance on how to
actually Implement these rules properly
many people would like to see it
scrapped but they want to see it paused
for this election because they say that
people just are simply not ready voters
and councils are not ready but there
will be some Les who say well is this
really that big a deal you know you need
a photo ID to get into bars to buy
alcohol cigarettes leave the country
what's the response to that that
question Sally takes us nicely on to the
bigger issue which is this is an issue
for some people of just basic uh Freedom
why should you be forced to have an ID
card essentially so that you can
exercise your fundamental right to vote
now it's very easy to make the arguments
as you just did well you know lots of
people in there's a countries across
Europe doing this Northern Ireland is
doing this you have to have ID cards for
so many aspects of life but people on
the other side of the argument say look
this is a basic a basic right that
underpins our Democratic institutions
and if you take this away then you are
eroding people's civil liberties via the
back door
now you mentioned the conservative MP
David Davis earlier who's clearly not a
fan of all this we are a country that
doesn't expect the government to know
everything we do you know the rest of
Europe they have identity cards maybe
they're comfortable with that we are a
stronger better and Freer democracy than
any other country in the world and one
of the reasons is we don't have to walk
around with a pass to do things why do
people feel so worried about this is a
concept
this has been a political debate in this
country now for many years it's hard to
remember a time before we had a
conservative government but there was a
time for that and and the black
government uh tried to bring in uh ID
cards it became secretary David blunkett
that tried to push this forward and they
they really wanted that to happen at the
time it was about protecting in a kind
of world of global terrorism it was it
was about domestic safety that's the
issue that was happening at the time
yeah because they were introduced after
9 11 right but then they were scrapped
by the successive conservative
government if I'm not mistaken why was
that well there was a huge backlash if
you think back to that time it was a
very live public debate and David Davis
was actually at the center of that he
stood down as the MP in his own
constituency to trigger a by-election
over this issue of ID cards there was
too much in the end opposition in the
House of Commons and I think potentially
more widely in the country and there
just wasn't the support
to get it through so it's always been an
issue on the one hand of saying this
when it comes to voter ID this is about
ensuring the Integrity of our electoral
system before that it was about safety
and policing which is why many countries
across the world have ID cards but in
this country there has always been a
very vocal and in the end very
successful opposition to that which says
that this erodes our civil liberties too
much it should not be compulsory
especially to just to be able to uphold
your basic rights to have an ID card and
I think that's the concern that's coming
up with people like David Davis and
others which is we've had this debate
already it's already been decided now
what's the government had to say about
all this what's their response to this
criticism Liz we don't know whether this
will come in the future but there hasn't
been enough opposition ahead of this
policy coming in to stop them going
ahead with it and they continue to give
the same justifications that they did
when they uh brought this policy into
legislation which is that it already
happens and it's absolutely necessary to
protect the Integrity of our voting
system they're not prepared to bend on
this I think in the end the crunch
moment will be when we come to the local
elections and we see the impact that
this has had but I do think there are
really serious questions for the
government to answer because when we
come to the general election you know we
are already having boundary changes
which will favor the conservative party
if we also see voter suppression of
Labor voters in that general election as
well and it's a very tight election then
you do have to wonder why the government
are pressing ahead with these kind of
reforms this is already passed in
legislation it's going forward it's
going to happen
um at the moment it seems like we can't
go backwards
the depressing thing is there's probably
not going to be many people listening to
this podcast that don't have the right
ID it's people that aren't engaged in
the political system that will be
penalized that feels really unfair so in
terms of giving advice to people you
know if there are any campaigns locally
to try to raise awareness of this if you
care about it I would get involved in
those thanks very much indeed for all
that Insight Liz good to talk to you
thanks for having me
my thanks to Liz Bates and to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Sally Lockwood this episode was produced
by Annie Joyce our editor is Philly
Beaumont
[Music]